building cloud-native applications can
often be difficult setting up the right
environments
accessing client libraries and figuring
out an easy way to deploy and debug your
application is time-consuming
to help you solve these challenges we
built cloud code cloud code is a set of
ide plugins that allows you to write
deploy and debug cloud native
applications quickly and
easily cloud code supports a number of
ides including visual studio code
jetbrains ide such as intellij and cloud
shell editor this way you can leverage
the tools you already know
let's dive deeper into how cloud code
helps you write deploy and debug your
code faster
first a collection of starter templates
showing best practices in a variety of
languages are available out of the box
and you can run these on google
kubernetes engine or cloud run with just
a few clicks
as you build out your app you can easily
enable and integrate numerous google
cloud apis from your ide
you can also leverage cloud code secret
manager integration to access
and manage sensitive data like api keys
passwords
and certificates right from your ide and
if you aren't someone who loves writing
yaml files
cloud code improves your yaml authoring
experience with features like code
snippets and inline documentation
once you're done writing your code and
those pesky yaml files it's time to
deploy
if you're trying to run your kubernetes
application on a local kubernetes
cluster cloud code makes it easy to
deploy to docker desktop or we'll create
and start a mini q cluster for you if
you don't have one
when developing cloud code can
automatically rebuild and redeploy your
code every time you make a change
it even supports hot reloading
individual files that change to the
container without a rebuild or redeploy
so you see updates in under a second
even better cloud code works with any
kubernetes cluster
be it on google cloud or any other cloud
after deploying you may discover issues
in your application
cloud code is here to help by providing
the same debugging experience you're
used to in the ide
even when debugging a remote kubernetes
cluster or a serverless application
just place breakpoints then debug your
code in your kubernetes cluster or
locally on cloud run emulator
if you need to dive deeper cloud code
also comes with a built-in log viewer to
help you monitor and debug issues with
your kubernetes and cloud run services
right within your ide now you know how
cloud code works to improve your
experience creating cloud-native
applications
within your favorite ide by helping you
write deploy and debug your code faster
we hope this short introduction to cloud
code gives you all you need to get
started
cloud code is the most productive way to
build cloud-native applications
and you can give it a try by going to
cloud.google.com forward slash code
also you can reach out to us via slack
you can find us using this link with
cloud dash code as the channel name